Zoho so Zoho has their own University
and the graduates of that make up 15% of
their work [__] which is pretty
insane
so hundred so first follow up on last
time I was talking about corporate
universities I'm gonna keep talking
about anything education cuz I just love
it I had a lot of people reach out to me
about that really okay so I went back to
my notes I already had these notes but I
just wanted to mention a couple of them
so hamburger you that's the McDonald's
119 full-time professors I thought that
was interesting
there's I don't how you say this
Croatoan Ville that's from General
Electric
so Kaiser just opened up their own med
school which I find really interesting
because it's what that's exactly what I
was talking about where you want your
own pipeline of doctors so you create
your own med school then some companies
do it more like training Apple
University Deloitte University I think
those are more like just a training
program so you could be a better
employee that's that's different
another one that I thought was
interesting so we talked about Soho Soho
has their own University and the
graduates of that make up 15% of their
work flow [__]
which is pretty insane so a hundred they
have a maybe they have more than a
thousand people I'm not sure exactly how
many total it is to Google IT support
certificate has 75,000 graduated
students which is pretty crazy so I
think this is gonna be a big trend so
it's the opportunity to be a company
that can create these education so I
think what you can do is so there's
these companies that are called what the
hell are they called I know one is
called to you or something like that
that's the name of one of their
companies so there's a set of companies
that what they're doing is they say hey
university hey Berkeley you should have
an online degree and 4 years
universities we're not so interested in
this and then they saw how much money
gets made by online degrees and so
they're like okay we'll take that money
and so they don't want to you know
Berkeley doesn't want have to sit there
and build out an online degree portal
that has like the technology the service
acquire students like Berkeley doesn't
know how to do any of that [__] right so
there's a couple there's three big
companies that basically go to these
universities and they say hey do you
want to offer an online degree we think
it brings this much incremental revenue
to your University and
we will run the whole thing for you so
you don't have to lift a finger and
here's the but we want you know 30% of
the tuition revenue and right so what
happened is all the university said yes
so there's a billion-dollar company
that's doing this that basically offers
this to all the universities so this if
you go look all these you know
traditional universities now have a
online degree or certificate certificate
program that they offer and it's run by
these other companies I forgot the name
of what these companies are called
there's like some generic term but I
think you could be that for corporations
and so I think you could go to a
corporation and say hey would you like
to basically have your own you know
developer bootcamp or university for you
know essentially we're gonna pop out
people who are like management
consultant types and it's good for your
brand to get students early and anytime
you hire one of them we take essentially
a recruiter fee and we'll run the whole
thing for you and so I think that's one
way you could take advantage of this
trend
[Music]
you